♪ ♪
>> Greg: HUNTERS NEW DOOZY,
SPENDING HIS DAD'S CASH ON A
FLOOZY.
WHAT'S A FLOOZY?
HUNTER BIDEN ALLEGEDLY SPENT 25
GRAND FROM AN ACCOUNT LINKED TO
JOE BIDEN TO PAY FOR  --
RECEIVED RECEIPTS AND TEXT
MESSAGES FROM THAT FAMOUS
LAPTOP.
IT TOOK PLACE IN LOS ANGELES AT
THE CHATEAU MARMONT, WHICH IS
FRENCH FOR CHATEAU MARMONT.
IT'S WHERE JOHN BELUSHI DIED 39
YEARS AGO WHEN "SNL" WAS STILL
FUNNY.
AFTER SEVERAL DRUG AND
ALCOHOL-FUELED NIGHTS WITH AN
ESCORT, AND I DON'T MEAN FORD
ESCORT, KAT, ALTHOUGH THEY ARE
FETCHING, HUNTER HAD A BENTLEY
WRAPPED UP A BILL OVER A
THOUSAND BUCKS.
HE CONTINUED CHARGING SEVERAL
ACCOUNTS, THINKING THE PAYMENTS
NEVER WENT THROUGH.
THAT'S WHEN THE SECRET SERVICE
ALLEGEDLY GOT INVOLVED AS
EVIDENCED BY THESE TEXTS FROM A
FORMER SPECIAL AGENT.
"COME ON, H, THIS IS LINKED TO
THE CELTICS ACCOUNT, OR
CELTIC -- D.C. IS CALLING ME
EVERY TEN.
LET ME UP OR COME DOWN.
I CAN'T HELP YOU IF YOU DON'T
LET ME."
FOR THOSE OF YOU PLAYING AROUND
AT HOME, CELTIC WAS JOE 'US
SECRET SERVICE CODE NAME WHEN HE
WAS VICE PRESIDENT.
IT'S EVEN ON HIS
[INDISCERNIBLE].
SO TOO BAD FOR HUNTER THAT THE
SECRET SERVICE CAN'T PROTECT YOU
FROM YOURSELF.
IT'S LIKE MY ACCOUNTANT SAID TO
ME AFTER LOOKING AT MY TAX
RETURN, YOU CAN'T WRITE OFF
SECRET CAMERA IN KAT'S OFFICE.
PETE, THE WORST PART ABOUT
HUNTER BIDEN'S SEED GIVES PARTY
IN A BAD NAME.
IF YOU GO OUT WITHIN THE THE
NEXT DAY, IT'S NOT LIKE HAD LIKE
TO DO THAT AGAIN.
>> REALLY?
>> Greg: YES.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT, BUT HE DOES
SEEM TO HAVE AN UNLIMITED
CREDIT CARD, SO THAT IS SOME
SORT OF A LIFE GOAL.
IT IS AMAZING THE TYPES OF
THINGS, IS THIS WHAT THE
SECRET SERVICE IS SUPPOSED TO
DO?
>> I DON'T THINK HE WAS EVEN
UNDER SECRET SERVICE PROTECTION.
THE ANSWER IS NO.
>> THANK YOU.
TO SAVE HIM FROM OVERCHARGES OF
HIS FEET
--
YOU READ THIS ENTIRE STORY, IT'S
INSANE.
>> Greg: EVERY TIME YOU READ
SOMETHING WHAT HUNTER BIDEN IT'S
INSANE.
THIS MIGHT BE THE ONLY TIME HE
EVER USED PROTECTION.
[SCATTERED LAUGHTER]
>> TOUCHE.
>> Greg: STRIPPER, BABY.
MY YACHT.
>> I THOUGHT YOU WERE GOING TO
LOOK AT ME.
YOU KNOW WHAT, EVERYONE HAS A
LITTLE DIFFERENT JOB WHEN THEY
START.
THIS SCREAMS OF PARENT TO ME.
THE SECRET AGENT PROBABLY GOT A
CALL FROM CELTIC, HELP ME, MY
SON IS DOING IT AGAIN BECAUSE
WHEN YOU'RE DEALING WITH A DRUG
ADDICT WHO WILL WIPE YOU OUT
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T THINK THAT
SHE RAN UP EVERY CREDIT CARD AND
OF COURSE IT WAS LIKE MY DAD'S
VICE PRESIDENT, CHARGING.
>> WHY DOES HE HAVE HIS DAD'S
CREDIT CARD TO MAKE A COUPLE AS
A TREAT.
>> PARENTS HAVE BOUNDARIES.
WHY DID THAT ONE KID RUN AROUND
AND KNOCK OVER STUFF?
MY KIDS WOULDN'T DARE.
HE UNDERSTANDS -- BUT THIS IS
WHERE IT WAS -- THE FIRST THING
TALK ABOUT THE PROGRESSIVE
ATTACK.
THEY MADE A DEAL WITH A MODERATE
IN HIS COMMON SENSE AND BACKING
OFF FROM DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
HE'S BACKING OFF FROM UNIVERSAL
THIS AND GET RID OF THIS, SO ALL
OF A SUDDEN NOW WE COULDN'T GET
A STORY WHEN FOX WAS COVERING
HUNTER BIDEN.
WE DON'T KNOW IF IT'S A LAPTOP.
AND NOW THIS IS HOW WE GET RID
OF JOE BECAUSE HE DIDN'T DO WHAT
WE WANTED TO DO.
NOW HUNTER BIDEN STUFF IS COMING
OUT AND CNN IS LIKE THIS IS
REALLY HARD -- YOU KNOW, THIS
MUST BE SOUGHT FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
NOW IT'S A PROBLEM BECAUSE NOW
THE DEAL -- THE WATER IS
BREAKING COME OF THE CIVIL WAR
IS GOING TO START BETWEEN
PROGRESSIVES AND MODERATES
BECAUSE HE'S NOT PLAYING BALL,
SO NOW THEY'RE GOING TO GO AFTER
HUNTER BUT THEY ARE TRUTH
SEEKERS.
WHEN WE DID IT WE WERE
DISGUSTING AND ATTACKING AN
ADDICT'S LIFESTYLE.
>> Greg: DIDN'T EXIST.
THE LAPTOP -- THE STORY DIDN'T
EXIST, THE TECH GIANTS
ACTIVELY -- ACTUALLY BURIED IT.
I IMAGINE IF THIS WERE A TRUMP
OFFSPRING --
>> OH!
>> Greg: I KNOW THAT'S A
CLICHED QUESTION AT THIS POINT,
BUT IT HAS TO RUN THROUGH YOUR
HEAD THAT LIKENESS -- WHAT YOUR
FAMILY WENT THROUGH EVERY DAY
BECAUSE YOU ARE SIMPLY RELATED
TO THE PRESIDENT AND THEN
COMPARE IT TO WHAT HE IS NOT
GOING THROUGH.
IT'S ONLY THE DAILY MAIL THAT IS
INTERESTED IN THIS IN
"THE NEW YORK POST."
>> IT'S SO SAD ACTUALLY BECAUSE
WHENEVER MY FATHER-IN-LAW WAS IN
OFFICE, WE ALL KNEW THAT WE WERE
A REFLECTION OF AMERICA AND WE
TOOK IT VERY SERIOUSLY TO BE
PART OF THE FIRST FAMILY OF THE
UNITED STATES AND WE WANTED TO
ACT APPROPRIATELY AND DO THINGS
THAT WERE OUTSTANDING.
TO SEE THINGS LIKE THIS, I MEAN,
THE NUMBER OF TIMES HUNTER BIDEN
HAS BROKEN THE LAW, HE'S
ADMITTED TO SMOKING CRACK.
I KNOW SMOKING PARMESAN CHEESE
ISN'T ILLEGAL, JUST
QUESTIONABLE.
BUT NOW WE KNOW HE'S PAYING
PROSTITUTES ON POSSIBLY HIS
FATHER'S CREDIT CARD.
IT IS OUTRAGEOUS STUFF.
IT JUST MAKES ME SAD REALLY FOR
AMERICA THAT THIS IS A MEMBER OF
OUR FIRST FAMILY.
VERY SAD TO SEE.
>> Greg: HAVE YOU EVER USED
YOUR DEBTS CREDIT CARD FOR
ANYTHING CLOSE TO THIS?
>> NO.
AND THAT'S WHY HE DOES HAVE IT
VERY GOOD, ESPECIALLY FOR A
CRACKHEAD, BUT PART OF ME FEELS
A LITTLE BAD FOR HIM BECAUSE
IT'S GOT TO BE REALLY HARD FOR
HIM TO JUST HAVE A FUN WEEKEND.
IF HE SETS THE BAR AT GETTING SO
BLASTED WITH AN ESCORT THAT
YOU'RE SO HIGH YOU CAN'T FIGURE
OUT HOW TO PAY HER WHEN IT'S
OVER.
YOU KNOW, HE DOESN'T PROBABLY
GET EXCITED FOR LIKE DINNER AND
A MOVIE.
>> Greg: I MEAN, WHEN YOU'RE
PUTTING --
>> IT DEPENDS WHAT'S FOR DINNER.
BUT BROCCOLI, STEAK, AND CRACK.
>> WATCHING A MOVIE OR AM I IN
THE MOVIE?
>> THERE YOU GO.
>> Greg: WHY WATCH IT WHEN YOU
CAN STAR IN IT?
DID YOU SEE WHAT HE DID -- THE
THINGS HE DOES WITH THE SNACKS
AND THE MINIBAR, WHAT HE DID
WITH THE M&MS.
VIDEOS OF ALL THAT OUT THERE.
I DIDN'T WATCH ANY OF THEM MORE
THAN THREE TIMES.
HE'S THE KIND OF GUY THAT DRAGS
EVERYBODY INTO HIS PROBLEMS AND
IF YOU TRY TO HELP THEM, HE
GUILTS YOU.
HE WAS A MAN, WHY ARE YOU
BOTHERING ME?
THIS GUYS TRYING TO SAVE YOU AND
HE'S BEING LIKE YOU ARE
BASICALL